so i want to address both points today
especially in the light of concerns you
may have heard
in some other countries about the oxford
astrazeneca
vaccine first the independent medicines
and healthcare
products regulatory agency has reviewed
the evidence
as it does every week they've confirmed
that the benefits of the vaccine
in preventing covid far outweigh
any risks and people should continue to
get their vaccine
when asked to do so and june will say a
little bit more about that
in a moment it's also very important for
our european friends
that today the european medicines agency
has come to a clear scientific
conclusion
and i quote this is a safe and effective
vaccine we also saw yesterday the
evidence from public health
england that a single dose of either
vaccine provides
60 protection against getting covered
and reduces the chances of
hospitalization
by 80 percent and the risk of death by
85
so the oxford jab is safe and the pfizer
jab is safe
the thing that isn't safe is catching
kovid which is why
it's so important that we all get our
jabs as soon as our turn
comes and as it happens i'm getting mine
tomorrow and the center
where i'm getting jabbed is currently
using the oxford astrazeneca vaccine
for those receiving their first dose and
that is the one
i'll be having and let me also assure
you
if you come forwards after receiving
your letter we have the jabs
for you we've always said uh that in a
vaccination
program of this pace and this scale
some interruptions in supply are
inevitable
and it is true that in the short term
we're receiving fewer vaccines
than we had planned for a week ago that
is because of a delay in a shipment from
the serum
institute who are doing a herculean job
in producing
vaccines in such large quantities
and because of a batch that we currently
have in the uk
that needs to be retested as part of our
rigorous safety program so
as a result we will receive slightly
fewer
vaccines in april than in march but that
is still
more than we received in february and
the supply we do have will
still enable us to hit the targets we
have set
that means that by the 15th of april
we'll be able to offer a first
dose to all of you who are over 50 as
well as those
under 50 who are clinically vulnerable
we will have the second doses that
people need within the 12-week window
which means around 12 million people
in april and we will still
offer a first dose to every adult
by the end of july so
there is no change to the next
steps of the roadmap
we've now vaccinated over 25 million
people across
our entire united kingdom more than the
entire population of many countries
and our progress along the road to
freedom
continues unchecked we remain on track
to reclaim the things we love to see our
families
and friends again to return to our local
pubs our gyms and sports facilities
and of course our shops
all of course as long as the data
continue to go
in the right direction and we meet our
four
tests and the way to ensure
that this happens is to get that jab
when your turn
comes so let's get the jab done
thank you very much i'm not gonna hand
to to june
thank you prime minister and good
afternoon the mhra
has been carrying out robust safety
vigilance
in tandem with the covid 19 vaccination
program
our role is to continually monitor
safety
during widespread use of a vaccine to
confirm that they're performing as
expected
to identify any new side effects that
arise
and to ensure that the benefits continue
to
outweigh the risks we've been able to
gather a large amount
of data on the safety profile of the
available vaccines
and have done a rigorous scientific
review of all the available data
with regards to suspected blood clots
our review alongside the critical
assessment of leading independent
scientists
in the commission on human medicines
shows that there is
no difference that blood clots in veins
are occurring
more than would be expected in the
absence of vaccination
for either vaccine the public can have
every confidence in the thoroughness of
our review
we have also received five reports of a
different
a rare form of blood clot in the
cerebral
sinuses cerebral sinus vein thrombosis
or csvt occurring together with lowered
blood platelets
shortly after vaccination with the
covid19 vaccine astrazeneca
this type of blood clot can rarely occur
naturally
in unvaccinated people as well as in
people
with covid 19 disease a further review
of these events is ongoing
but a causal relationship with the
vaccine has not
yet been established and the rate of
occurrence of these csvt events
among the 11 million people vaccinated
is extremely rare while we continue
to investigate these cases as a
precautionary measure
we would advise anyone with a headache
that lasts more than four days after
vaccination
or bruising beyond the site of
vaccination after a few days to seek
medical attention
and we will communicate further on the
outcome of this further review
when it's complete the mhra assess this
data
alongside the benefits of the vaccine in
preventing covid19
with its associated risk of
hospitalization
and death and determined that the
benefits firmly remain
to outweigh the risks so you should
continue
to receive your vaccine when you get the
call or the second dose
as soon as you're contacted and i want
to end
by expressing our sincere gratitude to
those who have sent reports to the mhra
and remind everyone that you can report
and you should report
all suspected side effects to covid19
vaccines
through the coronavirus yellow card
scheme
thank you prime minister thank you very
much
june uh let's go to chris you anything
to add to that thank you very much let's
go to let's go to jane from
buckinghamshire
good afternoon are the uk able to
provide stats
to prove that the astrazeneca vaccine is
safe and therefore alleviate the current
fears of blood clots in the eu
thank you thanks jane i'm i'm going to
pass that straight back to
to to june then to chris yes we can
we're committed
to transparency we publish every week
all the suspected adverse drug reaction
reports that we receive
and our report includes further
information
on any trends and it will certainly
communicate
all the data and the stats around the
particular
issue of blood clots thank you
i mean the thing i'd add to what dr
raine's just said
uh is firstly that all of medicine is
about saying look what are the
potential risks of the treatment and
everything that you take every drug
every vaccine every operation has gone
ahead and have some
risks often very small including drugs
that people are very used to like
aspirin so for example that can cause
clotting sorry bleeding that can cause a
whole variety of problems
and yet we all would see that as a
normal drug that people would just have
in their
their bathroom cabinet so all drugs have
some
side effects that are rare the question
is are the benefits big enough to
justify that
and what we have here what dr rayne has
laid out is an incredibly
small potential risk and even this is a
potential risk not one that is
certain so five people out of the 11
million that have been given the vaccine
in the uk so far
against the really very substantial
protection that these vaccines given
that the az vaccine as well as the
pfizer vaccine give
to people against this really common
disease
and i think it's important to remind
people that at this point in time
we're still in a situation where the uh
the uh the office for national
statistics
i think that one in 270 people uh have
got covet this is still
a common disease and it is a very
dangerous disease for many people
people dying people getting significant
blood clotting problems that's one of
the risks of covid
people having long term uh physical and
mental effects from covid
so this is a very significant disease
that is very common
with a very effective vaccine and two
vaccines in the case of
az and pfizer and real
issues that we always have to think
about with all drugs but they are so
much smaller
than the benefits of getting the vaccine
so the risk benefit is really strongly
in favor of getting vacci vaccinated as
mhra have said today and as the ema
the excellent uh european medicine
safety agency has also said today so
this is a universal view
it's also the view of the world health
organization wha
thanks chris uh barry from berkmontren
barry asks in the light of the european
president uh
the european commission president
threatening to block the export of
vaccines
how will this affect the general public
who are waiting for the second dose of
the fisa vaccine which is
which is produced in in belgium uh well
uh barry thank you very much i think
that
people should be uh under uh no
uh anxiety or no misapprehensions about
that we will get a
get on and deliver all the the second
doses of the
of the pfizer and um
it's very important to stress whatever
you uh may hear about
uh the pressures that different
countries are under
to deliver vaccines for their for their
public
um this is these vaccines are a
a multinational effort they're produced
as a result of international
cooperation and i want to stress that we
in the uk
uh will continue to uh to to view it in
that spirit and to
we don't have any uh bans on on
exporting
stuff and we'll continue to cooperate
with our
with our european friends uh let's go to
fergus walsh of the bbc
thank you prime minister um is there a
danger
that the unfounded concerns about the
safety
of the astrazeneca vaccine might put
some people off
from having their jab what would you say
to them
and for professor witty how important is
it that
the under 50s uh get immunized
as soon as possible thanks well
fergus i think the the best testimony uh
that
i can offer about the the safety of the
uh of the pfizer and the oxford
astrazeneca which seemed to be pretty
much i identical in in safety terms is
really what you've heard
uh just now from uh dr rain and
and professor witty i think that they
are uh you know
uh uh medical professionals whose whose
view it is that these are safe
and effective vaccines and that's been
confirmed today
uh by the european medicines agency and
i think that's a
i think a voice that will be heard
around the whole of the
of the european union and that's that's
all to the good
um i mean i just to add to that uh the
the overwhelming professional view
of doctors around the world and other
health professionals
is these vaccines are highly effective
against a dangerous infection that is
common
and they are safe very safe relative to
the risk of the infection so
the first thing is to say there's a very
strong professional consensus on that
and it is clear that the british public
also have taken that message and if you
look at the numbers that people have
coming forward
forward for vaccination uh well over 90
percent
in the age groups that have gone through
their vaccination have chosen to take
this up so there is
the general public is uh as always
sensible and steady on this they
understand this is a dangerous disease
an effective vaccine and one that's got
very low
uh side effects compared to the risk of
catching the disease
in terms of the over the under 50s we
the the biggest risk uh as everyone uh
will by now know
is in those who are older or have health
conditions so it's quite right that
those were
were prioritized and the jcbi
prioritization made that clear
and in terms of people who had who have
sadly died from uh
kovid 99 of people who died would have
come from either
people over 50 or with pre-existing
health conditions
who are in the groups that are currently
vaccinated so that was the absolute
priority
and we know that a second vaccine on top
of the first
adds to the protection so it is really
important
that uh people who are invited for a
second vaccination
uh come and get it and then in
particular these people in the in the
first
uh the jcpi groups one to nine the
people over 50
and with health conditions so really
important they do that once those are
vaccinated
it is also very important we start going
down the ages because people can
continue to have significant health
problems
uh in their 40s 30s 20s and occasionally
even younger than that but
it decreases over age but there's still
significant health problems all the way
through
so it will be critical that once we got
through the first group who are the ones
who are most at risk
we go on to do this protection and it
does one additional thing which is the
higher the proportion of the population
are vaccinated
the the smaller the risk to everybody so
by being vaccinated someone protects
themselves and if they
take the second vaccine they protect
themselves even more
but if they also have the vaccination
they reduce the risk
of passing on kobe to people around them
so that's what we really want is
everyone to be vaccinated for their own
protection
and if everybody is protected that also
protects everyone
else in society thanks folks emily
morgan
itv thank you prime minister and
you said that there's no change to the
roadmap but you have also said in the
past that we will only move to the next
phase of easing of lockdown
if we pass four tests doesn't this
vaccine supply
issue mean that we are actually going to
fail the
first test which is the continued
successful deployment of the vaccine
uh no um i think the short answer to
that though
we'll be able to uh to meet our targets
in in exactly the way that uh
that i described by by april the 12th
and by
uh and by july and that's the that's the
crucial thing that will enable us to get
on with
uh the the steps on the timetable that
uh that we've set out so
uh april the the 12th may the 17th uh
uh june 21st we will continue all the
uh the unlockings that uh uh that i've
set out if
if the the four tests as i said continue
continue to be met thank you very much
tom newton done times radio
thank you prime minister question for uh
professor witte
are vaccine centers gps whoever banned
from administering
vaccines to under 50s if they had stock
left over if they'd done all their group
sixes if they'd done all their over 50s
and question to prime minister on
india's role
in stopping the syrian institute from
exporting four million doses
you just said they they're just done
what was the indian government's role
in that do you know and furthermore if
they have indeed stopped the syrian
institute from exporting four million
doses to us
is that not the same vaccine national
nationalism that you're quick to call
the eu out on have been sun
so far over india um
chris i mean the re the nhs has been
really clear that what they want to do
is to prioritize the
people in the the over 50s and those in
the high-risk groups
plus health and social care workers uh
and
uh carers of vulnerable people and
they've done that for a really
obvious reason that i think everybody
accepts and what those leading this
have said and i completely agree with
this is we must at this point
really prioritize uh the possibility
that we don't miss
anybody leave anyone behind because
we're racing down the ages and just to
give
uh a uh something you know the the
society of actuaries
gave some numbers on this to explain why
this is so important
and what they show what they said was
that if uh if you assume the
vaccine was completely effective which
isn't completely affected but very close
to
uh very very close to that for practical
purposes
you would need to vaccinate 20 people in
the highest
risk group to actually prevent one death
by the time we get down to the ones
people in their 50s who are otherwise
well don't other have other problems
you need to vaccinate 8 000 people to
actually prevent one death the point i'm
making is
the key priority at the moment is to
find all the people who've
not yet had the opportunity to be
offered a vaccine in the highest risk
groups complete on that
and then we absolutely then want to go
down further down the ages
but that's that's the reason for the
decisions
yeah and tom on your question about the
serum institute of india i i want to
thank the
the serum institute of india for their
heroic role
in producing huge quantities of uh of
vaccine
and uh and the indian government hasn't
uh
stopped uh any export there is there is
a
delay as as i've described as as there
is
uh very frequently in vaccine rollout
programs but
this is believe me by no means the end
of the story of uh
the uk's uh relationship with the serum
institute of india
and uh and you know we hope to make uh
further progress over the over the weeks
and months ahead there is there is a
huge amount of work that we want
to do together and this is this is just
the beginning
thanks very much uh tom i think you
wanted to come back on something
we gotta we do you want to come back
there tom very quickly yeah
it's incredible for that delay if not a
ban have the indian government delay
that
no no no the there there is there is a
there is
there is a delay is there as there often
is uh calls for
for various technical reasons uh but
uh we hoped as i've said to continue to
work very closely with the
uh serum institute of india and indeed
with partners around the world
including uh on the european continent
so this is a this is a big international
effort uh we're going to continue uh as
as the uk
uh to be to be global in our outlook as
as you would expect us
uh to be um steve swinford the times
uh prime minister you've previously
called for an amnesty for migrants who
are in the uk illegally
how comfortable are you with the idea of
sending asylum seekers overseas for
processing
and professor witte the latest figures
suggest that just one in 16 000 tests
on school children have come back
positive how confident are you that
we'll be able to proceed with the easing
of the lockdown
on april 12th steve
the first uh point about uh
the illegal immigration into into the uk
uh is that and you're perfectly right i
think when when
uh people have been here for a for a
very long time
uh and haven't for fallen foul of the of
the law
uh then it makes sense to try to
regularize their status but that
actually is
is pretty much what already happens
under under under the existing
rules but when it comes to uh what the
home secretary was
was setting out i want to be clear the
objective here
is to is to save life and avert
human misery because people are crossing
the channel
uh who are being fooled who are being
uh conned by uh gangsters into paying
huge sums of money
uh risking their lives people have died
making this
uh trying to make this crossing and it
is a
a deeply repugnant uh traffic that we
we need to stop and that's why the home
secretary has set out the
the tough series of proposals that that
you've seen but the objective
is a humanitarian and one and a humane
one
which is to to stop the uh the abuse of
these people by
uh by a bunch of traffickers and and
gangsters that's what we're
we're trying to do thanks thanks very
much i'm sorry for the schools
sorry sorry chris on on schools uh just
three points
and the first of which is a huge thank
you to teachers and other
school staff who have done a really
terrific job
in making it as safe as possible for to
all children to come back and
remembering of course that
children are not the group who are
heavily affected by this uh by this in
this infection but they are important in
potentially in the transmission and what
they're doing
uh in the schools is really going to
benefit the students
uh the staff and wider society uh in
terms of um
we are expecting that schools going back
uh will put some upward pressure on our
we've said that right from the beginning
that's that was an accepted thing that
that is likely to happen
but the uh the road map was planned with
that
possibility absolutely in mind when the
prime minister announced it
and what he also said and this is just
reiterating what he said
was he wants and ministers want to be
based on data not dates
and we have not yet got to the point we
can see the full impact of the school
uh the schools being open again and
therefore what we will need to do
is to re-look at the data once it comes
in but it takes a while
for the data fully to reveal itself and
to be properly analyzed
in a way that the prime minister and
other ministers can make a decision so
it is important that we stick to this
data not dates approach
but there's nothing at the moment that
is
flashing red lights beyond what you'd
expect which is of course when there are
schools open there is slightly greater
in uh possibility
of transmission we'll just have to see
what the data show thanks
i just say steve on schools i was
actually to school in my
apartment in my constituency today and
the the feeling that was they were so
glad
to be to be back it was obvious from the
what all the the pupils said and i want
to i want to echo what chris said i want
to thank all the teachers
who've done an amazing amount of work
getting their their schools ready
uh all the parents who put up with uh
locked down for so long and
worked so hard and uh i think that i
think i'm right in saying
that the attendance today is actually
higher than we would normally expect it
uh to be
at this time of year and uh it was it
was very very good to see the
the enthusiasm for for being back at
school and and
uh the the steps that uh schools are
still taking to
um and rightly taking to ensure that uh
it's kobe's secure
uh mesa hall of the express
uh thank you prime minister uh if i can
ask professor whitty
have you seen any evidence uh that the
suspension of the oxford vaccine in some
european
countries has had any impact here in
terms of people not turning up for
appointments or perhaps asking for an
alternative if they do
and uh prime minister next week is the
anniversary of the
start of the first lockdown i think
you've said that you'll privately
observe a minute silence as the married
curie charity has asked people to do
should we see it as a national day of
commemoration for those that we've
lost in this pandemic and have you given
any more thought to a permanent memorial
to them
on the question you asked me i mean
there are anecdotal reports which i'm
sure will be accurate that um in some
places a few people have not
uh turned up immediately after they
heard the news i suspect a lot of them
will
think about it see the very reassuring
data that the mhra is given that dr
rayne laid out earlier
the very reassuring points that the
world health organization made
the very reassuring things that the
european medicine agency made
and the overwhelming view of the medical
and nursing and other health professions
and they will realize that this is
something that having had a pause for
thought
they want to do but the numbers were
very small who did that actually
almost record numbers have been going
through in terms of numbers of people
taking up the vaccine
the overall there is no evidence of a
significant problem that people do not
want vaccination
and anybody who is doubtful about this i
would encourage them just to think
through
the dangers of covid how common it is
and the safety of the vaccines this is
something that absolutely
is in their interest as well as everyone
around those interests uh for them to
take
yeah and mesa on the anniversary of
course i'll be marking it
uh as i'm sure uh millions of others
will arrive around the country
uh and on the uh idea for a national
memorial
um uh yes we will certainly be pursuing
that and
a lot of good uh suggestions have
already uh already come in and you'll be
you'll be hearing more about that in in
due course uh let's go to
alex brown of the scotsman good evening
uh for you prime minister when will
cross-border travel
be relaxed enough for the 800 000 scots
in england to go home and see their
families again
and secondly do you think nicola
sturgeon should resign if you broke the
ministerial code
and would you expect the same of your
own ministers
uh well alex i i hope very much that
uh we'll be able to move around as one
united kingdom according to the
timetable set out on the
uh on the roadmap and i hope that uh
everybody will
show common sense in application of the
rules
uh around the country and as i've said
earlier earlier on
uh there's no change to the road map uh
as a result of anything uh to do with
the
uh vaccine rollout which continues uh
which continues well
and uh i think your second question was
an attempt to
uh he gave me uh quite properly
uh to get me to comment on something
which i think uh uh
is properly and rightly left uh uh to
uh the uh parliament in uh in scotland
to to address and to the scottish
electorate
okay everybody thank you very much thank
you